we will now develop the solution to the
linear least mean squares estimation
problem we want to find coefficients a
and B that make this expression this
mean squared error as small as possible
we will approach this problem by
proceeding in two stages in the first
stage we assume that the choice of a has
already been found and concentrate on
the question of choosing B now if a has
been found and has been fixed to a
specific number then this quantity here
is a specific random variable and what
do we have we have a random variable
minus a constant and we want to choose
that constant so that this difference
squared is as small as possible in the
expected value sense so essentially we
are trying to choose a constant B that
estimates this random variable in the
best possible way but this is a problem
that's familiar to us and we know that
the best choice of B is equal to the
expected value of that random variable
and using also linearity this expected
value can be written in this form so if
we know a this is how B should be chosen
let us now move on to the choice of a
since we know what B should be equal to
we can rewrite this expression that we
are trying to minimize by substituting
our choice of B which is the expected
value of theta minus a X and this is the
quantity we want to minimize what is it
we have a random variable minus the
expected value of that random variable
squared and then we take expected value
this is just the variance of the random
variable theta minus a X this is the
variance of the difference of two random
variables because the two random
variables are dependent this is not just
the
of the individual variances but we do
have a formula even for the general case
and the formula tells us that the
variance of the difference of two random
variables is the variance of the first
random variable plus the variance of the
second and when we pull a outside the
variance that gives us a contribution of
a squared and then we have a cross term
because of the minus sign here the cross
term will have a minus sign we have a
factor of two and then we want the
covariance of theta with a X and because
we have seen that covariance is behaved
in a linear manner we can pull a outside
the covariance and this is what we are
left with this is the quantity we want
to optimize with respect away and to do
this optimization we just set the
derivative with respect to a to zero and
that's going to give us two a times the
variance of X minus twice the covariance
of theta with X equal to zero from which
it follows that a should be equal to the
covariance of theta with X divided by
the variance of X so we have found what
a should be once we know what a is we
know what B should be equal to so we
have solved the problem and here's the
form of the solution this coefficient
here is the coefficient a so we have
here the term a X and then this term
together with a times the expected value
of x this corresponds to the coefficient
B it's also instructive to rewrite this
solution in a slightly different form
involving the correlation coefficient
recall that the correlation coefficient
between two random variables is defined
as the covariance between the two random
variables divided by the product of
their standard deviations
using this relation we can now write the
coefficient a as the covariance which is
Rho times Sigma Theta Sigma X divided by
the variance of X which is Sigma x
squared and after we cancel a factor of
Sigma X from the numerator and the
denominator we see that a is also equal
to Rho times Sigma Theta divided by
Sigma X and this gives us this
alternative form for the solution what
we will be doing next will be to
interpret this solution and also to give
a number of examples